H welcome uh back to the show
congratulations this game uh it started
off as early as mve to there was no
opening preparation he surprised you
because he usually doesn't play the
Sicilian in fact at move one tell us
about your reaction and how did you
approach that
game yeah well he's been playing C5 in
Blitz like at the levitov tournament he
played a lot of C5 um online um I don't
know the last time he played C5 in a
classical game it must be years maybe
you guys can check I I I don't
uh in cassco was quite a surprise but um
I briefly I checked like a couple of his
games in C5 E6 but I didn't prepare
anything um but I guess I had a nice uh
Contra
surprise what was your uh counter
surprise well the C3 E5 idea and the
funny thing about this is is that um I
was playing in Mexico the RO Juniors and
next to me there was a game like Yan
subel against rudic marcan and I saw
that um this idea was played and I was
so impressed by the idea um and honestly
I've never checked this line once in my
life um but it looked nice I thought it
would be a nice surprise and like from
what I remember the game that seemed
like enough uh preparation um so I guess
uh the fact that I don't pay enough
attention to my own games helped me out
here because I remember seeing this game
next to me and being so uh so impressed
um by what was happening um so that's
why I decided to go for for this line
and um it worked out well because
obviously he's not uh going to be aware
of this type of sideline if it's his
first time playing uh this this type of
idea absolutely still it was a very
imbalance very complex uh game but it
felt like you just understood the
position better at at this point after
Bishop takes C4 Queen takes C4 how did
you assess it obviously he was trying to
start an attack on the king's side but
finally you got the light score Bishop
you have the two Bishops Advantage it
felt good from a practical perspective
coming from your side did you feel the
same way yeah I know I felt very very
good here um I think once I saw H5 I
thought the this is this is the biggest
Bluff in the world I'm not going to uh
uh okay maybe it's a fine move but I
don't really uh H5 with the H4 is
definitely not working um so I was not
worried about opening up my own f file
um so that's this was good yeah I guess
G4 yeah so this was good yeah G4 G4 was
yeah he mentioned after the game that he
should have played Knight H4 after
Knight D4 it felt very very bad um yeah
I take take Rook F3 was my idea yeah and
then
um well no Bishop H4 Rook F3 and I
wasn't sure I didn't see Rick C8 but
yeah I have like Rook H3 I saw this Rook
F3 Rook H3 maneuver but I wasn't sure
how to evaluate but I thought there's no
way I can there's no way I'm not better
here is that what you guys were
discussing after the game no he just
told me that he missed after Knight F D4
that I could play Bishop takes D4 that's
that's all all we discussed yeah Bishop
takes D4 and when did you feel like
you're by the way I ask you this moment
G5 yeah G4 G5 was a very good idea a but
after Bishop to E3 you had 33 minutes on
the clock and you ended up spending a
lot of close to 30 minutes King so King
F yeah so King F1 Queen E5 um that's
what I was B6 I obviously understood
that I was fine so Queen takes E5 right
uh Rook takes B7 Queen takes E4 MH
Bishop takes E4 Rook takes H4 uh Bishop
takes C6 and uh here I yeah obviously
Rook A7 is winning but I was trying to
make C5 work work um C5 C5 uhhuh I SP my
time C5 but he has yeah Rook Rook h8
Rook dh8 Bishop G2 and then I thought
Bishop F4 and I couldn't figure it out
okay yeah oh yeah I saw Rook B3 I wasn't
sure how to evaluate this but this is
not that clear right I spent I spent all
my time calculating this when just Rook
takes A7 it just game over it was very
stupid I think maybe the nerves uh were
affecting me because obviously I should
just play uh Rook T to7 it's just game
over just what's the point of this Rook
H7 if he goes King Rook to
h8 B7 and then there's no mate on H1
because so he had he has to play um he
has to play Rook D6 but after Bishop G2
it's just game
over I don't know why eventually it took
me 30 minutes to realize this apparently
so but uh yeah B6 obviously like I saw
um and I thought I played okay after
this maybe I wasn't that precise
was prettyy happy with this it was this
moment when you didn't necessarily let
him back into the game but you gave him
some opportunities oh wow how is he wait
wait so what was the moment can you oh
so this is actually right now yeah so
knight2 G2 what were yeah knight2 G2
King E3 mhm yeah King E3 Rook
H5 we weren't really sure how to assess
the one whether you have enough King F2
Rook E5 for a win or if he man yeah you
probably have you probably have like you
know 10 only moves in a row and then
maybe you hold right right yeah
that's yeah no it was very difficult
with with the time situation he was uh
putting a lot of pressure so I couldn't
really find the clear way um still H I
mean I guess I think after that you uh
took over the game and you made the best
moves in the position
was very this was and then 81 yeah and
okay just he blundered 191 yeah this is
just at loss yeah well Hans
congratulations big victory for you how
do you feel uh to be beating a
2700 plus level
player well leavon is such such a legend
so uh it's it's obviously an honor to to
play against him and to win the game uh
the last three games we've played
actually the first game uh I had almost
basically winning position the second
game had great positions so uh I feel
like I've showed my good chess in our in
our three games um uh the last year's
championship game even with black I was
doing well so of course it's it's an
honor for me to beat him he's like uh
one of the greatest uh players of of
modern times um you know he was like
number two in the world for a very long
time or one of the top 10 players so
it's um it means a lot to to beat him
and um especially after he sort of
slipped away the last two times uh it's
nice to to to win it's you and Fabby at
the top right now closely following each
other how do you see this uh race
playing out in the next few
rounds well um he did just beat Andrew
who's who's been struggling so I guess
it'll be pretty it'll be sort of crucial
to to beat beat him since he's sort of
the on paper at least uh very very uh
he's the Target um so I think this will
mainly come down to um beating sort of
the lower seats um because the top
players uh are quite difficult to beat
so this is a very big win but
um uh you know I'm playing well um in in
all five games that I've played uh I've
had a winning position um I was winning
against Sam um winning against dorius so
I think that I'm I'm definitely creating
chances in the games um I'm outplaying
my opponents um I think this game I I
showed a good level of technique and
consistency um and I just need to keep
up my level but uh I feel like uh I can
outplay uh anyone uh so um I'll try to
keep playing my best chess Katherina you
have a question for Hans yeah Hans I
have to ask because during your um
previous interview you said that you
really enjoy inspiring young minds and
you like in engaging in community
service so how was your community
service during the rest day it was great
um uh what we did is we had um basically
we played on the
the this like the board that people
what's the demo board the analysis board
the big board that people and we had a
te board yeah and it was yeah
demonstration board yeah sorry and it
was um we basically played hand and
brain and all of the kids uh got in a
line and each one would come up and say
peace uh so it made things quite
interesting because there was varying
levels of skill
um I actually remember I can uh I was
thinking I've been thinking about this
game so basically it uh maybe you can
bring up a board I'd just like to show
the game if if you can bring up a board
it's very interesting since you asked
and you're so curious you got it so uh
it was uh it was E4 E5 F4 um EF uh
D4 and they played
D5 um um Bishop takes F4 Bishop E6
Bishop B5 check and then I was really
hoping because so here they said Bishop
so I'm trying to think okay let's go
Bishop B5 check they'll see that C6
attacks the the bishop and then they'll
say bishop and I can go Bishop D3 but
after
C6 they said uh they said
Knight so so after C6 I went Knight C
Knight C3 C takes B5 Knight takes
B5 um Knight A6
and then now they say
Pawn so I said uh I said
E5 and um then they said Bishop Bishop B
before check
C3 Bishop A5 Knight
D6 uh King f8 uh Knight F3 Knight
E7 uh
castles and then they went um what did
they
play let me think what did they play
trying to think what did
they by the way as you're thinking who
was the brain who was the
hand I I was the hand that's that's what
so each kid would would be contemplating
what move they're going to play and they
would sit there so nervously and and and
uh it was uh but basically what happened
was is
uh let me think
basically we got like
95 and uh I sacked a rook and everything
worked out quite beautifully there was
some very painful moments lots of comp
something like this happened something
yes something like this
happened um perhaps I yeah so basically
something like this happened and uh we
won after sacrificing this piece and at
some point my team just started sing
every single perfect piece they were
reading my mind we had great Synergy um
so I was very very uh happy with how
they game went of course even such a
casual game among school kids I take
extremely seriously um this is this was
I'm not messing around you know Victory
must be attained at all costs any
emerging talents out of St Louis any
potential applicants to your scholarship
pass um I I think that um you know uh uh
I from the club has told me that uh
there's like you know a lot of Chess
programs it said you almost 100 um chess
programs so I'm sure that if you give it
some time there will be some emerging
chess talents from St Louis um you know
the main chess talents from America come
out of California and New York um mostly
because of the the school programs and
then the access to tournaments
um uh so I I think that um maybe a
couple more years and we'll start to see
some some emerging St Louis you know
talents from the you know Capital uh the
chess capital of America well
congratulations uh Hans big victory for
you we'll see you tomorrow
thank you our congratulations as well
indeed Hans